and while he won't be able to play in
the all-star game because of injury he
is captain for the second straight year
looking for some payback against
mr james here uh
lebron
kevin let me
let's just get to the news of the day
you know before we get into the draft
because
obviously everybody talking about the
trade deadline and brooklyn has traded
james harden paul millsap to
philadelphia ben simmons
seth curry andre drummond coming your
way your initial reaction to hearing
that this had gone down
i'm excited for our team looking forward
to finishing the season out
with these new groups
and these new players and you know it's
uh playoffs right around the corner so
we got a
fast track into you know getting getting
used to each other but i'm excited you
know i think everybody got what they
wanted
you know kevin uh i just got to say man
do you have a full-time psychiatrist on
staff dealing with all the stuff you
have to deal with in brooklyn
[Laughter]
what i got to deal with i'm making
millions of dollars playing basketball i
know that but you got to deal with the
james situation you don't deal with that
anymore you got kyrie going on i mean
it's always drama around that team so i
know you've got to have somebody to talk
to because it's hectic
i love my brothers regardless
you know uh
katie you know you look at what you guys
acquired
and what you guys let go obviously with
with james the floor was spread
differently
now ben being there seth what do you
envision in terms of when you come back
of the style stylistically that you guys
will be doing
i mean that's a good question
i feel like we got versatile players so
we'll have to figure it out and figure
out what works for us but i'm just
happy that we got guys that want to be a
part of this